[Music]
wondering what to watch tonight there
are a bunch of underrated films you may
have missed so far this year and they're
really worth checking out here are a few
hidden gems that may have flown under
your radar in 2019 the whip-smart comedy
egg stars Alicia Reiner as an artist
named Tina and Banga Akana Bay as a
husband Wayne Mad Men's Christina
Hendricks plays Karen Tina's so-called
best friend from art school a
compulsively cruel mother to be who
saves things like it can be weird when
you're with people who don't have
children Tina thinks she's gained the
upper hand when she invites Karen and
her husband Duggar played by David Allen
bash over to a New York loft to make a
major announcement
oh good that's thanks for the bubbly
blonde suricate keiki portrayed by Anna
camp she may seem ditzy but she's
certainly not innocent Phil of biting
wit and sharp social commentary egg is a
fiercely funny comedy of manners have
brilliantly explores the weirdness of
motherhood directed by Steven Soderbergh
high flying birds fly Lee subverts the
sports movie genre in a way that's both
stylish and admirably risky the film
centers around sports agent ray Burke
portrayed by Andre Holland after he
discovers a loophole during a
professional basketball league lockout
ray hatches a plan that could help him
advance his career and fulfill his
obligations to Eric his younger
basketball clients a prospect of forever
changing the world of pro basketball
proves hard to resist may I see a whole
infrastructure they're put to control
back in the hands of those behind the
ball instead of those open skybox shot
entirely on an iPhone by flying bird as
a kind of sleek aesthetic and structure
that grabs you by the wrist and pushes
you straight down the rabbit hole the
film at netflix in early February right
after velvet buzzsaw and Russian doll
premiered a lot of viewers probably
missed out on high-flying purr because
they simply had too many options to
choose from the good news is you can
watch it on Netflix right now score in a
vigilante actress Olivia Wilde plays
Sadie a domestic abuse survivor who sets
out to save other victims from the
violent partners meanwhile she continues
to hunt down a vile husband portrayed by
Morgan Specter he's such a despicable
man no
tear speak his name out loud my husband
he would set my bones after he broke
them and I broke the rules a vigilante
is explosive gritty and a fantastic
showcase of wilds talents reviews have
been hugely positive with Roger Ebert
calm claiming that wilds performance are
so committed that there are times you
may fear for her physical safety and
emotional health Mel Gibson and Vince
Vaughn portrayed two embattled police
detectives and dragged across concrete a
film that certainly bleak but also quite
good single ready it faster that's all
about the humor you get in this one the
gritty drama unfolds after the two men
gets unnecessarily rough with a suspect
and his girlfriend during a drug bust
when video footage of the incident gets
leaked to the press both detectives are
suspended from the force without pay
with no means of legally making money
they begin mapping out a dangerous plan
and things get very real very fast
while some audiences might find drugged
across concrete too brutal and
mean-spirited audiences who caught the
film during as limited release were
genuinely impressed and so were many
critics Entertainment Weekly hailed the
film assuring readers that if you're
wondering where this is all headed he
won't be disappointed when it finally
gets there to dust strikes just the
right balance of strangeness the
directorial debut of Sean Schneider is
an oddball dramedy that's truly
refreshing and original the story
revolves around Hasidic [ __ ] a small
portrayed by gaze of Rorick since losing
his wife Shmuel has been experiencing
and settling nightmares about her dead
body desperate to find some peace of
mind he recruits a community college
biology instructor named xalbert
portrayed by Matthew Broderick hoping
he'll teach him what happens to the body
after death and fear her solely
suffering she returns to tears this
unlikely pair engage in some bizarre
experiments and morbid misadventures in
an effort to seize most boundless
anxiety to dust as a film everyone
should say it's marvelously strange
truly original and mistakenly human
written and directed by Christian pet
sold Transit's utterly captivated
audiences during his limited release in
March 2019 this moving drama tells the
story of George a refugee fleeing
Germany and heading to France as fascism
rises in his home country
George is supposed to be two writer
named by Dale in Paris but he soon
discovers of the manners
committed suicide George then assumes
the writers identity and scoops up his
belongings boarding a train to
Marseilles a port city teeming with
other refugees once there George ends up
meeting Maria a woman desperately
searching for a lost husband who just
happens to be vital transit as a
genuinely moving film that garnered
loads of praise from critics with film
inquiry calling it a film of surreal sad
beauty that should not be missed if
there is any justice in the world
a kitty would be king and would have
reigned supreme at the box office but
alas the film went largely unnoticed
upon its release written and directed by
Joe Cornish the kitty would be king for
some modern spin on a very familiar tale
Lewis Ashbourne Circus plays
twelve-year-old students Alex Elliott's
who discovers he's the only person on
the planet who can pull the mighty sword
Excalibur out from its stone it's the
only weapon that can vanquish the
powerful sorceress Morgana portrayed by
Rebecca Ferguson
Alex gathers up his friends to service
as Knights and the whole crew enlists
the help of a backwards aging wizard
named Merlin played here by both Angus
Emery and Patrick Stewart together they
conspire to take down Morgana before an
impending solar eclipse lets her enslave
the people of England the sword choose
you why would we help you because you're
the strongest people I know you're my
Knights for whatever reason the kitty
would be king was a critical success but
a commercial failure although the movie
lost millions of dollars at the box
office you shouldn't let that discourage
you critics praised the film's
inventiveness and good-natured nurse
with the Guardian writing that this
movie is sentimental in all the right
places and impossible to dislike this
coming-of-age story is nothing like
you've seen before in don't come back
from the moon we meet sixteen-year-old
Micky played by Jeffrey Wahlberg the
young man is grappling with a profound
sense of abandonment his father played
by James Franco is only the latest man
in their California town to pack up his
bags and leave vanishing without a trace
as if he vaporized
just floated away it sounds like the
plot of a sci-fi series but don't come
back from the moon is rooted in a harsh
reality the fathers and husband and his
rundown desert community walk away from
their lives because they have nothing
better to do and they evidently don't
care that they're leaving their families
behind everyone in this family reacts to
the departure in a different way
Mickey's mother portrayed by rashida
Jones tries to resist self-medicating
with alcohol meanwhile Mickey does his
best to look after his younger brother
played by Zachary Arthur throughout the
film
Mickey develops a considerable
rebellious streak explores his sexuality
and tries coming to grips with a strange
new life released in a limited run in
mid-january don't come back from the
moon was praised by critics with variety
writing nuts the film was an artful and
affecting mix of harsh T defined
specifics and impressionistic
storytelling an unlikely charmer about
an unlikely friendship Pelton debuted at
the 2019 Sundance Film Festival on
February 1st before making its way to
Netflix later that month the film stars
mark Duplass and Ray Romano in roles
that are unlike anything they've done
before
when Duplass says Michael Thompson is
diagnosed with terminal stomach cancer
it seriousiy intensifies his friendship
with neighbor Andy Freeman played by
Romano best known as comedic actors
Duplass and Romano proved to be equally
adept at dramatic roles giving
themselves over to their characters in a
way that feels completely organic what's
most impressive about puddled CERN is
relative lack of dialogue which
immediately distinguishes it from other
dramas that involve the big sea
okay as you can see Michael and Andy
both have a serious aversion to small
talk which guarantees that every spoken
word is a meaningful one genuinely funny
and heartbreaking puddled son is a
moving film from beginning to end and
guess what it's available on Netflix so
you can check it out right now
just make sure you have a box of tissues
Haeundae you probably haven't heard of
the standoff at Sparrow Creek until now
the film didn't generate a whole lot of
buzz upon its release even though it
certainly earned a whole lot of
favorable reviews Henry Dunham's feature
directorial debut centered around an
ex-cop named Ganon who subsequently
joined the militia in Michigan the Croft
gentleman portrayed by James badge Dale
soon learns as somebody has just shut up
a police funeral what's worse the
shooter evidently belongs to Ganon's
militia but which of these dangerous men
did using his skills as an interrogator
Ganon grills each member until one of
them reveals himself to be the cop
killer the film opened in a limited
capacity in January a month up finds a
lot of films getting completely buried
that's a real shame too because the
standoff at Sparrow Creek deserves to be
widely seen reviews were glowing with
the a/v Club writing that there's a lean
punchy beautifully shot 70 sale thriller
underneath the controversial premise in
the icelandic survival film arctic
Danish actor masks Nicholson plays a man
who's lost alone and running out of
resources that the Arctic Circle
he misses out on a chance to get rescued
when a helicopter meant to retrieve him
crashes killing the pilots and injuring
a passenger now he must choose between
staying cooped up in a crash plane to
survive or traveling through an Arctic
wasteland in the hopes of saving himself
and the passenger guess what he
ultimately decides to do
Nicholson is subscribed arctic as one of
the most challenging projects he's ever
been involved with and critics have
assured that the grueling days on
location in Iceland were well worth the
efforts in its rapturous review seven
days roads
Mickelson gives an astonishingly
expressive performance and one is
essentially a silent film it will be a
cold day in hell before a better
chronicle of cold days and he'll comes
along
starring Emile Hirsch and John Cusack
never grow old centers around her she's
Undertaker Patrick Tate and Cusack's
ruthless outlaw Albert's who soon stakes
his claim on the formerly quiet town of
Gallo in 18-49 Danny Webb plays preacher
Pike who banned alcohol harlots and
gambling throughout the town creating a
kind of peace begging to be broken they
dragged this town in a dutch soon takes
an interest in filling puzzles with
liquor and saloons with working girls
and isn't long before the death toll
rises and Dutchess viciousness drives
Patrick to violence if you're a fan of
westerns you'll want to see never grow
old before you called yourself the
comedic chops of Madeline Sammy and
Jackie Van Beek are on full display in
the breaker operas a romantic comedy
executive produced by Taika Waititi Jena
Mela two friends who have turner cynical
views on romance into a lucrative
business venture if you have the cash
they can help you destroy your
relationship and next to no time really
what we do is we take unhappy couples
such as yourself and consciously
forcibly and irreversibly uncouple in a
film opened in New Zealand theatres in
May 2018 and made its way to Netflix in
February though the bloody comedy didn't
make a huge splash critics couldn't get
enough of its wacky sense of humor stuff
Magazine braved the breaker operas is
the funniest and most likeable film I've
seen this year go see it we
wholeheartedly agree this is a perfect
choice for your next Netflix and chill
dates particularly if you're looking to
break someone's heart check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
films are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and to the bail so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]